hey this is presto Walker and you're
watching mind your decisions today
everyone is searching for new ways to
teach mathematics what if we found an
education tool called multiply by lines
that did the following students love it
they learn it in their spare time and
they even share it with others it makes
sense students often say I finally
understand it it's beautiful
it makes math into an art form and the
method is rigorous it can be used for
arithmetic algebraic binomial
multiplication number bases other than
ten and so much more
shouldn't we be teaching this in every
classroom but after 10 years the method
is virtually unknown outside of a few
viral videos let's spread the word in
this video I'm actually going to share a
new discovery involving the multiplied
by lines method but before I get to that
let's do a quick recap of how to
multiply numbers by lines let's say you
want to multiply 12 by 13 for the one in
12 we'll draw one line for the two and
12 we'll leave some space and then we'll
draw two lines for the other number
we'll draw lines in the other direction
for the one in 13 we'll draw one line
and then for the three and 13 we'll
leave some space and then we'll draw
three lines now we will group vertically
aligned intersections then we'll count
the number of intersections on the far
right there are a total of six
intersections in the middle we can count
there are five intersections and on the
far left there is one intersection we
then read the numbers from left to right
to get
the answer 12 times 13 is equal to 156
what kind of magic is this in 2007 this
visual method to multiply numbers took
the internet by storm bringing joy to
millions now it is 2018 for over 10
years
everyone missed a mind-blowing discovery
about this method using group theory we
can supercharge this diagram and solve
even more problems so what exactly is
group theory according to keep Konrad a
mathematician at the University of
Connecticut
broadly speaking group theory is the
study of symmetry what's it good for
well here are a few applications in pure
mathematics group Theory can be used to
help prove the impossibility of solving
the 15 puzzle or to prove the
impossibilities of solving a general
quintic that's fifth degree polynomial
using radicals in physics group there is
useful to help predict the existence of
particles even before they were seen
experimentally in chemistry group there
is useful for understanding the
structure of crystals and molecules by
studying their symmetries so group
theory is pretty useful as a whole so
what's an example of group theory the
introductory example is what are the
symmetries of a square alternately said
what kinds of rotations or reflections
will leave the square exactly the same
as it started now if you have a square
one thing you can do is you can rotate
it by 0 degrees you can leave it as it
is this is one symmetry now another
symmetry will be if you take the square
and you rotate it by 90 degrees the
square ends up exactly the same as it
started another symmetry is if we rotate
the square by 180 degrees another
rotation is a
we rotate the square by 270 degrees now
if we go one more 360 degrees that's the
same thing as a zero Degree rotation so
here are the four rotations which will
leave the square exactly the same as we
started but there are other symmetries
too one symmetry is if we do a vertical
reflection notice the square ends up
exactly the same as it started now we
can also do a horizontal reflection
another symmetry is if we connect two
corners and then rotate the square about
this diagonal we can do the same thing
for the other two corners and end up
with one more symmetry these are the
eight symmetries of a square and they're
known as the dihedral group of order
eight now the bottom row of symmetries
actually looks like it's completely
different than the top row but they
actually involve 90-degree rotations too
and it'll be easier to see this if I
illustrate the symmetries with my logo
so the first symmetry is doing nothing
that'll be my logo we can then rotate my
logo by 90 degrees we can rotate it by
180 degrees or we can rotate it by 270
degrees now let's go to the bottom row
and do the same reflections to my logo
what do we end up with well if you take
a look at these diagrams you'll notice
that there are actually hidden rotations
in them in particular if we rearrange
the diagrams as follows you'll see that
the bottom row the four squares are all
rotations of each other just like in the
top row so this will give us another way
to present these symmetries which will
be useful we can express everything in
terms of a single 90 degree of rotation
we'll call that R and a vertical flip
which we'll call s so the top row we
start out by having
a 90-degree rotation being labeled are a
hundred and eighty degree rotation is
two 90-degree rotations which is R times
R or R squared a 270 degree rotation is
rotating by 90 degrees three times or R
cubed
finally a rotation of zero degrees we'll
call one or the identity element now in
the bottom row
we can express everything in terms of a
vertical flip and a 90-degree rotation
that's repeatedly applied so the
vertical flip will be denoted as s the
second reflection can be expressed as
are composed with s we do a vertical
reflection and then a rotation notice
that we do this from right to left just
as we would compose functions the third
element in this row can be written as R
squared s this is a vertical reflection
and then two rotations the final diagram
is R cubed s this is a vertical
reflection and then three rotations but
did we overlook any symmetries how do we
know there are exactly eight symmetries
of the square well let's do a quick
proof I claim there are eight symmetries
of a square it's the dihedral group of
order eight there are no other
symmetries now to prove this let's take
our square and label the corners a b c
and d vertex a can move to any of the
four possible corners now once we've
selected where vertex a can be vertex b
can only be in two possible corners
because it has to be adjacent to a you
can either be counter clockwise to a or
it can be clockwise to a once a and B
are chosen C has to be opposite a and D
has to be opposite B there are no more
choices thus we can have
at most 4 times 2 which equals 8
symmetries of the square and we've
already demonstrated how to produce 8
distinct elements so this shows there
are at most 8 symmetries and we've
demonstrated 8 symmetries we've
established the dihedral group of order
8 so how can this help us and are
multiplied by lines well notice our
diagram if we remove these vertically
aligned groups and then we look at this
lattice that's in the center of the
diagram the x lines method actually has
the geometry of a square the four groups
of dots are like the vertices of a
square so let's use group theory on this
square like figure what will happen
first I'm going to change the diagram
into a rectangle and then I'm going to
smush it together so that we have a
square now let's apply these symmetries
of a square to this diagram one thing we
can do is that we can rotate this
diagram by 90 degrees what do we end up
with well let's examine this diagram
here we have one line followed by three
lines this will be the number 13 in the
other direction we have two lines
followed by one line this will be the
number 21 now we can count the
intersections to get the answer 213
times 21 here we have two intersections
here we have seven intersections and
here we have three so 13 times 21 is
equal to 273 rotating this diagram by 90
degrees solved an entirely new
mathematical problem incredible in fact
what happens if we do another rotation
let's rotate it so it's 180 degrees from
the original what will this diagram
correspond to here we have 21 and in the
other direction
we have 31 so this diagram is 21 times
31 we can again count the intersections
to get the answer to this problem and we
get 651 we've solved another problem so
let's go ahead and do another rotation
we now have another diagram this will
correspond to 31 x 12 what's the answer
to this problem
well we'll count these intersections and
we end up with 372 one more rotation
will bring us back to the start but now
we can use the other symmetries so let's
do a vertical flip of this diagram we
now have another mathematical problem
here we have three lines followed by one
which is 31 here we have two lines
followed by one which is 21 so we have
31 times 21 you'll notice these digits
are exactly the mirror image of the
original problem the digits are an exact
reverse order of 12 times 13 and in fact
the answer will also be a mirror image
instead of 156 we get 651 now we can
continue finding the symmetries by doing
a rotation here we have the problem of
21 times 13 and we can again solve this
problem and we'll get 273 we can do
another rotation and we'll get another
problem which is 13 times 12 which is
156 we can do a final rotation this will
be 12 times 31 which equals 372 one more
rotation will bring us back to where we
started
so let's recap what we
just solved we start out with the
symmetries of a square using group
theory and we apply these two x lines
group theory we start out with the
diagram then we can rotate at 90 degrees
to get another problem we can rotate it
180 degrees to get another problem we
can also rotate it by 270 degrees to get
another problem we can also reflect this
diagram vertically and then we can do
rotations of this reflection so we end
up with these potential diagrams we have
solved for distinct multiplication
products and the bottom row is they're
mirror images
so to recap since 2007 tens of millions
of people have seen the x lines method
now with the power of group theory we
have discovered the truly awesome power
of visual multiplication I need your
help to spread the word about this
discovery please share this video thanks
for watching these math videos which can
be watched for free inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they already have over a hundred
million views let's share the beauty of
mathematics with your help we can math
the world a better place please
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos watch and share all the mind your
decisions videos email me a puzzle or
math topic presh
and mind your decisions comm if you so
choose you can check out my books which
are linked in the video description and
you can support me on patreon to earn
exclusive rewards thanks for watching
and thanks for your support